velvet buzzsaw has just received its
world premiere at 2019 sundance festival
whilst the film is not out until Friday
on Netflix we got to watch an early
release of it and whilst it may divide
some viewers there's still a lot to take
from it now this most likely won't
overtake Byrd box in terms of tapping
into the Internet's consciousness
however there are some massively
interesting and abstract aspects to it
that really elevated above your typical
horror Netflix should be commended for
their original horror premises and the
platform always seem to take risks with
velvet buzzsaw being no different the
premise itself centers around a series
of paintings by an unknown artist being
discovered and from these supernatural
forces spring forth to take out the
greedy art world
unfortunately the creative team are
stifled slightly by cliches and what
starts off as a unique film ultimately
succumbs to the confines of the genre
the work is of course as much as satire
as it is horror and the majority of the
performances within the film
are really hamming up just how
pretentious and superior are the art
scene seemed to act above the rest of
the world this of course leads to a lot
of joy when they are inevitably taken
down one by one and makes for a gripping
watch one of the main takes from the
film is that art is pointless if no
one's there to see it and this certainly
speaks for the film itself without a
Netflix I imagine that the majority of
viewers would not bother to watch this
but due to the platform's reach millions
will however it won't be for everyone
and I would recommend that you'll like
or dislike for Nightcrawler should
decide whether you watch this or not
ultimately this feels like another
parody of a world that is rarely put to
film and if you find that interesting
enough as an idea then you will enjoy it
I did have fun with a film even if I
found the characters slightly difficult
to relate to and the movie will no doubt
start February off with a bang and I
can't wait to see the conversation that
has brought from the peace Velvet
buzzsaw gets a 7 out of 10 so what did
you think of the film and do you agree
with my school comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of Netflix's korean zombie
horror Kingdom which will be linked at
and this is a channel for people who are
heavy into horror so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]